contre le coronavirus christian estrosi
ne ménage pas ses efforts
sept cent cinquante mille masques des
gants des blues ou encore des visières
de protection 25 tonnes de matériel au
total sont arrivés sur le tarmac niçois
la mi journée en provenance de canton en
chine
ces 25 tonnes de matériel pour
lesquelles nous avons beaucoup travaillé
auprès de production et et d'industriels
chinois dont il fallait s'assurer de la
certification dans certification
chinoise de compatibilité avec
certification française puisse d'abord
en matière de logistique être rassemblés
sur un même aéroport et nous avons
choisi l'aéroport de canton mais en même
temps puisse avoir l'accord des douanes
chinoises
un moment où il ya des tensions
internationales couvre-feu surveillance
par drones désinfection des rues usage
de la chloroquine au chu obligation du
port d'un masque après le déconfinement
depuis le début de l'épidémie le maire
les républicains de nice multiplie les
initiatives et tient à se démarquer du
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron ça n'est
que parce que nous avons réussi à
présenter un plan de vol d'un décollage
de l'aéroport de canton via directement
la plateforme aéroportuaire de nice avec
une escale à dubaï pour faire le plein
que nous avons eu le feu vert des
douanes chinoises pour l'embarquement il
y à 24 heures de cela qu a permis l
satin avions de décoller et d'un autre
côté l'accord du préfet des
alpes-maritimes et des doigts de notre
région pour qu'il y ait aucun droit de
réquisition qui souhaitent opérer sur
cette marchandise
de la communication politique fustige
l'opposition dans la cinquième ville de
france
reste que selon certains observateurs la
cote de popularité de l'ancien ministre
serait à la hausse